yo homie come to ask you a bunch of
questions I wanna have them answered
immediately what a story mark this film
was on a lot of lists and I had never
heard of it before in my life I did some
research on it it came out on September
9th 2001 that's bad timing for a
theatrical release yes so I feel like
after 9/11 nobody wanted to talk about
this piece of shit
yeah but they should have this movie is
one of the worst horror films I've ever
seen John I want to watch it I am not
exaggerating my friend why what's so bad
about it
everything Casey Affleck one on a record
I looked it up and said this was one of
the worst sets he'd ever been on there
this and the movie drowning Mona where
his two least favorite sets of all time
so basically the film is about this
group of friends who are college
students and they go to this rave where
it's like a bunch of like punk heavy
metal everyone's wearing black and
instead of like getting marked with a
stamp on the way in okay they're marked
with a brand and then this this weird
group of people start following her
everywhere and by the way guys I'm sorry
I have to spoil this movie do you mind
John I don't give a shit okay
that's away all right so it opens before
they go to that party with this random
girl getting attacked on her way home
from that rave okay they slit her wrists
and squeeze blood out of them into like
a vial okay and that's the opening scene
all right so then they go to this party
and after this party they they start
driving and they get into a car accident
and Casey Affleck is the boyfriend of
this girl and she's driving and he dies
and how does he die in the car accident
and she feels so guilty but the problem
is the next three minutes are a montage
of like the next two weeks and you just
see here at school starting to get used
to it
okay you see her at class at campus and
then all of a sudden everyone's parting
again it's they gloss over this Hort
this horrific death I I'm not even
getting into the editing okay John is it
shot like a shitty music video yes yes
and it's filled with like punk rock
music from the early 2000s that by
Evanescence in it or some it sounds like
a movie that would have Evanescence it's
all that type of thing and the company
that made it is called artisan
entertainment now they made they were
involved in Blair Witch Project yeah and
that was a huge success and when Book of
Shadows Blair Witch 2 came out they're
the reason that that film went from
being a satirical comedy about the
obsession of Blair Witch fans that and
they they made them do reshoots with
like extra punk rock and gore scenes to
make it an actual horror film and they
ruined that movie yeah this is what they
were obsessed with in the early 2000s
this crazy goth punk rock heavy metal
horror they were obsessed with it
artisan was and the entire film is
filled with these random sequences where
men start following her home from school
the worst part of it is is the forced
sexuality of this movie there are so
many scenes that are so incredibly
uncomfortable there's a sequence where
Elijah Dushku and Melissa Sagemiller the
two actresses they're painting their
dorm room and they start going like and
like throwing paint on each other's
chests that's not the crazy part okay
keep going the very next scene they jump
in the shower together talk slower with
their clothes on they use loofahs and
clean the paint off of each other's
chests in the shower with their clothes
on these are friends sure they're not
lovers they're friends yeah that's what
friends do yeah Jon you and I take
showers and wash each other all the time
you know we will only if we get paint
splats true there was that one time yeah
so that's just one okay there's another
scene where the lead girl is walking
through a library and she hears this
sound and behind a bookshelf she moves a
book and sees Elijah Dushku and another
random girl eating each other's faces
like full-on Spiti tongue kiss okay it's
exactly like softcore porn no setup for
a lesbian relationship of any kind
nothing it's just it's just in the movie
it's like a reshoot scene to add
sexiness the most fucked-up part of it
is she's really bothered by it like
she's really mad that her friend might
be a lesbian
that's the part that's the conflict in
this holy shit later in the movie she
walks up to the girl and she's like
you're disgusting or I was like holy
fuck this is 2001 like were we like past
that by then yeah it's not 1958 oh my
god it's like this it's unbelievable
this movie so what about all these
people trying to kill people yeah okay
so this crazy cult cult where this rave
happens and I'm not even mentioning how
Casey Affleck schoo stir up everyone hey
does he look like a ghost that's faded
and no security no he just looks like a
dude Steve he's not even like ghostly
pale no no so a Casey Affleck dead body
just shows up yes it's incredible dude
and wes Bentley yeah one of the worst
performances I've ever seen in my life
I'm not even look I'm not exaggerating
this dude my ghostwriter I I did yes
when I watched this movie I turned it on
I put it in I was about to go to bed I
was getting tired I was captivated by
this movie because it's so bad I'm
telling you I was riveted by its
awfulness its I I almost want to review
it because I looked it up on YouTube I
couldn't find anything really yeah it's
just open for the slaughter John I you
know what I think this movie was doing
I'm gonna look at it from a marketing
perspective okay they knew they had a
junky piece-of-shit movie but they
thought hey we put enough boobs in here
and girls kissing girls yep little boys
will like this yep and they'll rent it
from Blockbuster
because we still have blockbusters and
early do that yes that's exactly it all
it was that's exactly it so this girl's
running around she's trying to free
herself from this cult she's seeing
weird things she doesn't understand why
her friends so gross and likes girls now
which still blows my mind yeah still
blows my mind that that was a subplot
inch of course she's seeing her dead
boyfriend everywhere so the ending of
the film okay is a giant twist of course
ooh I can't wait where we find out that
it's literally all a dream oh but of
course
now I've seen other films that have the
dream subplot that use it in a very
unique way a film I really do love and I
won't spoil it if some of you haven't
seen it but this film basically she
wakes up in the hospital and we find out
she has just woken up from that car
wreck and Casey Affleck is still alive
but her other two friends I believe
they're dead and they're the ones who
she wasn't good they're the ones that
she got annoyed with Shh
okay and so it's okay that they're dead
because in her dream they annoyed us the
audience oh yeah they deserve even
though that even though that didn't
actually have no we didn't get a montage
of all the crazy things that happened in
what we thought was the movie and we see
what happened to her when she was on the
gurney and how it somehow connects now
the problem is this is not a terrible
idea I've seen something like this in
another movie that as I said I like okay
the problem is the execution and and the
way the film thinks it's so clever and
the editing John I am Telling You there
is a shot in the final cut she slams her
hand down on a table and her mouth says
fuck you Raven I rewound it multiple
times because what we actually hear is
fuck Raven the word you is not even the
word they forgot to dub it in it's not
even in there man whoa now the original
car was pg-13 the DVD is called the
killer
and it's rated R with blood and of
course a lesbian scene yeah which
probably wasn't in the pg-13 version I
had another question about the lesbian
scene I'll get I'll get to that but
maybe that's why maybe the DVD wasn't
even fucking completed and they just put
it out they didn't care yeah so your
kids boobies man of course yeah well my
question about the lesbian scene Chris
is you saying everything that happened
in reality kind of comes from the dream
and they're connected somehow now tell
me what happened in the reality that
would translate to two girls taking a
shower and wiping paint splatters off of
each other absolutely nothing okay you
know what a bit just hearing it you know
what a bit more clever except if she had
like blood splattered splatters on her
and like they were wiping that off sure
but her dream it's like a lesbian paint
splatters no it does okay and and you
know you know I mentioned the opening
scene where a random girl was followed
home by a cult and then her wrists are
slit and they take her blood okay
because that's before the car crash that
just that's just nothing it's nothing
John that just happened who the hell
knows that was just made-up nonsense who
the hell knows what that scene means
it's just a bunch of fucking scenes I'm
telling you if there was a grade below
and F I'd give it I want to review it
just because I am baffled by how
terrible it is I've never seen this
might honestly be the worst horror movie
I've ever seen and I've seen troll 2
which i think is funny as shit it's
hilarious okay this is a bigger budget
movie made by a big company with tons of
actual stars in it and it's this bat it
might be the worst I've ever seen I need
to go watch this movie I have it on DVD
I there's only just a few scenes I need
to watch to understand I need it from an
artistic standpoint Chris I need to
understand this movie more if I'm gonna
do a hilarious you have to re-watch it
so we can watch it together I will join
in because I need to be part of this now
I mean I'm I'm in it I gotta watch it
yeah nobody seen Oh quick question yeah
does it show the girl whose arms are cut
and they drain our blood they show that
girl yep okay okay never mind okay
ever in the movie again I thought maybe
they could have had a twist or some
mystery maybe it was Alicia
Dooku or whatever her name is Count
Dooku
Dooku no no no no it opens with this
girl walking home from some party and
she starts getting followed and you see
her getting nervous about it's like and
then she's attacked Wow
never never explained that sounds like
about the biggest piece of shit I've
ever heard Jon it's insanely bad and I'm
almost positive that the only reason
more people don't know about it is
because two days later after it came out
9/11 happened and it wiped it from
anyone's mind who had seen it because
there was no other movie or anything
anyone wanted to talk about Zoolander
came out the following weekend and that
did pretty badly the box office because
nobody wanted to do anything everyone
was you know depressed I had to buy the
disc from Amazon and get it shipped to
my house and you know it was crazy like
I had to do it like I had to actually I
couldn't find it too I wanted to support
it I was like I'm gonna buy it I'm gonna
buy it on Amazon I want to know who
owned that to ship it to you and really
they get it and why did the omen they
probably owned it for the same reason I
own it like some bizarre curiosity where
we were just like what the fuck is this
thing I have to watch it it sounds
intriguing though thank you so much for
watching thank you John Force excuse me
thank you for listening I have to get
used to that thank you John for joining
me as well I was it's always a blast
come here and talk about random stuff we
never get to talk about on YouTube and
now I want to watch Soul survivors III
might go watch it right now uh-huh
guys thank you so much and please do
stay tuned for more I greatly appreciate
the support couldn't do it without you
guys
thank you we'll see you very soon this
conversation is over
you just talking and it's over
you